牵手中天
这不是一个公开的秘密吗
自动红军最厉害
邻居我们的邻居一日邻居我也有送花花给他
今晚一起过手
这个是80的
哎
我们今天这样试试看啊
好这样试试看
如果我一直这样做
抢走
还有哟不错哦的千手观音
♪ 我鞋穿不下 ♪
欢方就是啦啦不算啦
我这样还蛮帅的
身体不要晃
不是有一种这种可以换哦
可以啊
是不是有一个会会弹回来的那种
会打到脸部弹回来
是不是可以弄牙齿
是不是可以弄
会踢贾斯丁
芬达说会敲到牙齿
因为我已经看到两个rock敲到牙齿
真的那可能要先这样子
然后对眼睛还不敢睁开
毁了不帅哈哈
这怎么弄啊
任何勒索哎算了哈
谢谢哎是不是哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
好好笑哇
好多麦克风哦
哇塞诶
定做的太open了吧
Oh my god
张哦好好
My god
天哪哇哦又送我两赛文加在家里
如果突然想唱歌的时候
哇塞哇塞麦克风啊
香槟啊
第二天有香槟了
好着急哦
Ji love to re
哈哈喜
这不是一个公开的秘密吗
没有啦
我有哪有那么多福利
小酌怡情狗嘴
God
Unbelievable
源源不绝的idea
♪ P ♪
♪ 开始游戏 ♪
♪ 到时间就出击 ♪
♪ HIBACK拜拜 ♪
♪ 那一瞬间 ♪
♪ 我睁开眼 ♪
♪ I'm a i'm a take a fight ♪
正走中不中
嗯从伦敦特别回来看我的like back
每次都从伦敦回来看
我这么爱我
谢谢你
我也爱你
还有深圳哎
逐渐靠近你的
吓我一跳
你还好吗
OK吗
你其实只是在跟我玩一个综艺摔
对不对
♪ 我还太假 ♪
当心很可爱的朋友
这个真的很可爱哈
还有这边闯过社会
卖过萌
我说亲一个解说型next
哈哈哈啊
这么近那么美
你们都会啊
中国好多美
谢谢哈哈哈
我好
我会努力去的
♪ 我想去 ♪
♪ 你那一秒 ♪
♪ 心突然就回答 ♪
♪ 喧闹的街 ♪
♪ 没发现花蕾被遗忘在街角 ♪
♪ Day ♪
You get away
大家太可爱了
♪ 大家见妈 ♪